uh it was never gonna happen for me with
any of the girls in my high school and I
knew that and I did not attempt uh but
then luckily I mean I was on Freaks and
Geeks you know immediately after that uh
immediately after high school
immediately after like done with high
school
in uh June starting Freaks and Geeks
July
unbelievable yeah
um and so
after that I was like yeah you know uh
it's my understanding that uh people on
television have an easier go at this and
they like me I'm good I'm getting cast
what was that audition process I'm sure
you've talked about this was it
something you auditioned for repeatedly
uh not repeatedly like I've I've
repeatedly auditioned for things since
then no I went in and read uh just for
Allison Jones The Great casting director
Emmy award-winning for her work on
Freaks and Geeks by the way yeah uh uh
uh casting director Allison Jones so
first I went and I read for her and uh I
got the audition like any other I think
it was the very first actual pilot
audition I'd ever been set up with right
and that was only because Judd Apatow
and Paul feig were specifically looking
for unpolished non-like known TV film
actors like they they didn't want if you
had a crazy resume they were not
interested wow they wanted young people
that looked like real Unknown People
yeah so that's impossibly how I got the
call to go audition for this and
originally I read for the role that John
Daly uh played uh Sam Weir right and so
it says in the breakdown it's like oh
he's nerdy he's undersized uh he likes
doing impressions with his friends they
talk about comedy all the time I'm like
well that's me
um so I I hope this goes well and uh God
bless her my mother was like oh it says
he does Impressions you should do your
impressions and at the time I had again
I was doing stand-up and I used to do a
truly terrible impression of William
Shatner
which is terrible terrible like it was
not a good impression thing yeah it
wasn't even that good it wasn't even
that good it was mostly uh it was that
it was just that that's good though it
was good so
so I was like yeah all right fine so
when I go into the audition
um they always ask me do you have any
questions and I say yeah it says he does
uh Impressions I actually do a William
Shatner impression uh could I do that as
part of the audition and they're like uh
yeah we'll do it at the end okay great
so then I read the role of Sam Weir not
particularly well and then literally I
turned uh casting her like okay go ahead
and then I launch into my crappy Shatner
impression which was something directly
from my ACT I did him on Rescue 9-1-1
remember he used to host yeah yeah
tonight at all rescue 9-1
that's right anyway so so did you think
this was this didn't go well I no I was
like yeah it went fine but I've at that
point I had hundreds of auditions I and
you weren't getting tons no you go in
you do it you move on with your life and
um and I felt pretty good about it and
then
um like a day later they called and uh
like hey they want to read you for
producers
and I said oh great
um so that's a different character well
here's what happened okay so the real
story is uh Chad Apatow was looking at
the tapes and he saw that and my read of
the scene was not very good but he got
such a kick out of my bad Shatner that
he said oh you know what put that kid on
the Callback list if nothing else Paul
feig is coming in to do the first round
of callbacks that'll give him a good
laugh
like just have this kid do a show you
found out through just John and Paul
they both told me that story yeah
they're like no you only wound up on
that list because I wanted to make Paul
laugh that's it and so Paul was the one
who I went to do my callback for and
when I went in and I read for Sam Weir
again and then I did my chatner and then
Paul was like that's great that's great
you know what can I give you a different
character to read I was like yeah so
then he gives me Neil schweiber and I
take that outside and I work on it in
the waiting room for 20 minutes and they
were like you know whenever you're ready
just let us know
and so I looked at it I was like I feel
like I could do this too and then like
three kids later I go back in and I do
that for Paul and he was really into it
he was like no no let's try it this way
try it this way try it this way and so
and you were giving him what he wanted I
hope so I think so he did obviously um
and she was like okay great okay thanks
so much and I leave and then an hour
later they call again they're like okay
they want to see you again tomorrow
I was like okay great and so now I go in
and so now I'm reading for Paul and Judd
Apatow and Jay kazden the director of
the pilot and I walk in and Judd
literally says all right Levine warm us
up with some Shatner
and so I start with the audition this
time or the the impression and and then
we start doing Neil schweiber and same
thing we're working on it we're doing
this they give me an extra scene uh and
we just we're having goofy fun with it
were you nervous uh or just fun nervous
I was fun nervous I mean I think the
fact that I done stand up at that point
for so many years on stage in New York
like I didn't get the typical stage
fright stuff like and then also again
uh unnecessary confidence there's no
reason I should have been that confident
it was borderline arrogance right and I
was like I could I could do this I know
what they want
[ __ ] idiot who called you did your
manager call you when you got it so well
first they called me and that later that
night hey they want to network test you
oh you've got another one you gotta fly
to L.A oh boy yeah so the good thing
here though was and this is the only
time in my career it's ever happened boy
that really screwed me this being my
first job Judd told DreamWorks it was
the studio I'm not Studio testing any of
these kids I'm not gonna make him do it
twice I'm telling you who I want you
approve them I'm taking them to network
and DreamWorks said okay so you skipped
it so we did not have to do the studio
test just the network test right and uh
yeah so it was at the old NBC Studios in
Burbank yeah
um and we do a work session and at the
work session this is a lot for a TV show
a lot of to go through I'm you know what
this is yeah I mean I've done it but
I've never I mean I guess I have I
remember the community I I it was just
between me and Joe McHale and we kept
going in and out and then and uh yeah I
remember going he's gonna get it he's
the part I'm not mature enough he's
gonna get and he got him and remember
we've talked about that before when he
was on the podcast
foreign